uh how do you see why you done me you've
treated me very poorly i don't know why
i've always asked you why do you treat
me like a child
i'll always be your son but i'm
definitely not a small child anymore so
there has to be some kind of respect and
distance you know this is what you
totally don't understand
you think that because i am so connected
to you that i think you need me
have you ever thought that it was the
other way around that need to chew
i needed you
you're my son no matter how
old you are you're 75 you're still my
son
yelt trip guilt trip guilt trip guilt
turf hello my name is debbie
guilt trip guilt trip won't take a
vacation today guilt trip guilt trip
guilt what
guilt trip you guilt-trip me all the
time
36
13 don't matter what do you want from me
i just want no seriously what do you
want me as a mother what do you want
whatever i don't care this is ridiculous
i can't i'm sorry i tried
goodbye mom
[Music]
jesus i just want to talk to you this
won't have a relationship
hello just want to have a relationship
what
is this
i guess i'll get my tomorrow
i'm not i'm leaving for real she's
yelling at me she gave me disrespect
i don't want to deal with that
feel like
leave them
kawasaki you're not allowed back in here
go away spooky do this to me you don't
give it
do not care about me i do i love you no
you don't
you just said you know what you know
mom you've been there too much what the
[ __ ] have i done to you
for your life my entire life has been
your life you've been the bus driver of
my life
what the hell is wrong with you
your dad would be so disappointed in you
you know what carl we're done you treat
me like a second-class citizen [ __ ] you
[Music]
i'm done i'm done with my mother i'm
done with this bull guilt trip
[Music]
at this point i don't even want to come
back to the house i have no reason to
everything i needed was my wife
[Music]
you